[Music]
liberty has ruthless enemies but never
fear CNN's Andrew kasinsky is on the job
he is deeply alarmed that the new chief
of staff to national security adviser
john bolton defended anti-muslim and
far-right activists and a pair of online
columns
clearly all upstanding citizens in
Kaczynski's view should be up in arms
about this the latest indication of the
Trump administration's disquieting
dalliance with the far right but
Kaczynski's far-right bogeymen weren't
exactly Hitler and Mussolini it turns
out that in columns for Fox News written
in 2016 and 2017 fred flights as
vice-president of frank gaffney
think-tank defended in t Muslim
activists Robert Spencer and panel a
gala and far-right activist cliff
Kincaid from their designations as hate
groups by the Southern Poverty Law
Center an Alabama based nonprofit
activist group that tracks civil rights
violations and hate crimes his defense
highlights his ties to more extreme
elements of the fringe anti-muslim right
so says Kaczynski kasinsky produced a
quote from Fred flight's as evidence of
his perfidy smearing anyone who speaks
out against radical Islam is one of the
s plc's priorities accordingly it has
placed on its hate lists jihad watch and
its director Robert Spencer American
freedom Defense Initiative and its
director Pamela Geller my organization
the Center for security policy and our
president Frank Gaffney are also on the
SPLC hate lists due to our principled
stand against the global jihad movement
that's what Fred flight said that Andrew
kasinsky thought was so outrageous now
taking a principled stand against the
global jihad movement is what Kaczynski
apparently thinks makes one anti-muslim
and far-right but in demonizing his
chosen villains kasinsky revealed more
about himself than about us he wrote
breathlessly Geller is well known for
her inflammatory public comments about
Muslims and Islam
has long pedaled the theory that there
is a broad conspiracy among Muslims to
impose Sharia law in the US a broad
conspiracy among Muslims to impose
Sharia law in the u.s. inconceivable and
yet a captured internal Muslim
Brotherhood document says that the
Muslim brothers quote must understand
that their work in America is a kind of
grand jihad in eliminating and
destroying the Western civilization from
within and sabotaging it's miserable
house by their hands and the hands of
the believers so that it is eliminated
and the laws religion has made
victorious over all other religions
that's from an explanatory memorandum on
the general strategic goal for the
Brotherhood in North America by a key
Brotherhood operative Muhammad Akram all
the major Muslim organizations in the US
the Council on american-islamic
relations the Islamic Society of North
America the Muslim American Society the
Muslim student associations the
International Institute of Islamic
thought and more they're all listed in
the same document as partner
organizations in this effort but as far
as Andrew Kaczynski is concerned it's
all just a conspiracy theory cooked up
by Pamela Geller kasinski also notes
that I myself have said quote the harsh
reality is that you cannot tell peaceful
Muslims from jihad ease in any
discernable manner
unfortunately Kaczynski didn't actually
provide a way to do that he just thinks
it's terrible that I pointed out that
there isn't one I said that in a 2014
speech in which the next sentence was
this and so it is simply ridiculous and
suicidal to continue to import whole
communities of Muslims from hot jihad
areas like Somalia and Syria and
Pakistan into the United States and drop
them down into American communities now
let's look at the record Somali Muslim
migrant my hamid barry in february 2016
stabbed multiple patrons at a restaurant
owned by an israeli arab christian ahmed
khan rouhani an afghan muslim migrant in
september 2016 set off bombs in New York
City and New Jersey are can set in a
Turkish Muslim migrant in September 2016
murdered five people in a
in Burlington Washington - here add on
another Somali Muslim migrant in October
2016 stabbed mall shoppers in st. Cloud
Minnesota while screaming Allahu Akbar
Abdul Razak are 10 yet another Somali
Muslim migrant in November 2016 injured
nine people with car and knife attacks
at Ohio State University
72 jihad terrorists have come to the
u.s. from countries listed in president
Trump's initial immigration ban what's
more all of the jihadis who murdered a
hundred and thirty people in Paris in
November 2015 had just entered Europe as
refugees the month before in February
2015 the Islamic state boasted that it
would soon flood Europe with as many as
500,000 refugees the Lebanese education
minister said in September of that year
that there were 20,000 active jihadis
among the refugees in camps in his
country waiting to go to Europe on may
10th 2016 patrick Calv are the head of
Francis D GSI internal intelligence
agency said that the Islamic state was
using migrant routes through the Balkans
to get jihadis into Europe but Andrew
Kaczynski isn't worried about any of
that and he doesn't want you to be
either he just knows that it's wrong to
care now I started to wonder what was in
it for Andrew Kaczynski so I reached out
to him on Twitter and I asked him the
following questions hi Kaye file that's
what he goes by on Twitter I'm doing a
story about you please answer a few
questions number one how did you decide
that foes of jihad mass murder and
Sharia oppression of gays women etc were
worse than jihad mass murderers
themselves - why didn't you ask me for
comment in this piece defaming me did
you ask the other people you defamed for
comment 3 did you get paid by any
individual or group other than CNN to
write this story if so who for are you
aware that there have been over 30,000
jihad attacks around the world and an
even greater casualty count since 9/11
do you really think in light of that
fact that Islamophobia is a word
problem than jihad terror 5 are you
aware that Islamophobia is a propaganda
term that was specifically chosen as a
label to intimidate people into fearing
to oppose jihad terror and Sharia
oppression 6 do you think that if Bolton
flights Gaffney Geller and me are all
ultimately silenced by the smear
campaigns that you and others conduct
that the problem of jihad terror will
disappear 7
why do all CNN journalists and other
establishment media journalists reflect
the exact same point of view on these
issues do you think diversity of
thoughts should be valued as much as
diversity of skin color etc or would
that be Islamophobic 8 are you aware
that over a million Yazidis Christians
and others have been murdered displaced
or had their lives otherwise ruined in
recent years by Islamic Jihad EES do you
think those jihadis misunderstand Islam
how did this misunderstanding of Islam
get the widespread 9 are you aware that
the jihad agenda targets all unbelievers
do you believe that you will be spared
because of how useful you are to the
forces of jihad that's all for now Kaye
file I look forward to seeing your
answers thanks now of course Andrew
Kaczynski K file did not deign to answer
and so the questions remain what benefit
will Andrew Kaczynski get if he succeeds
in destroying Fred flights and the rest
of us what leads Kaczynski and his
fellow establishment media journalists
to work so hard to defame and
marginalize people who were trying to
defend basic principles of human rights
and the norms of free societies what
kind of ideal world is Andrew Kaczynski
envision one in which the far-right has
been completely destroyed and leftists
and Muslims live together in perfect
multicultural harmony one thing is
certain if Andrew Kaczynski succeeds and
attains his goals of destroying the
people he smears as far-right and
everything they stand for the chaos he
will thereby help unleash will
eventually engulf him whether he will
have the wit and the honesty to realize
and admit that he was wrong before the
jihadis blade slices through his throat
or those whom he loves are brutalized
enslaved is anybody's guess I'm Robert
Spencer Schulman fellow for the David
Horowitz freedom Center and director of
jihad watch this video has been brought
to you by the Center for security policy
[Music]